vodka it's the preferred poison Russians
dieters and college freshmen officially
the clear stock is simply ethyl alcohol
without distinctive character aroma
taste or color so what on earth is
inside this fire water well water of
course at its purest vodka is just
ethanol usually distilled from wheat rye
or corn but it has to be diluted with
water to forty percent by volume or less
the alcohol molecules get trapped inside
a cage of water some people say all
vodkas are the same but these alcohol
cages might taste different depending on
their structure those are the basics if
you drink the flavored stuff your vodka
could also have three hexanol it's used
as an aesthetic but that's not what's
making you know here it gives cream or
wine like flavors other flavor enhancers
there's citric acid used to smooth out
objectionable tastes and sometimes those
flavored versions include a tiny bit of
sugar depending on the distillation
other types of alcohol one sneak into
vodka propanol is a sign of poorly
distilled vodka but what you really want
to avoid is methanol usually it's only
found in the bathtub versions of the
style just two millimeters can lead to
blindness and 30 millimeters can kill
you of course if you drink enough
ethanol can be poisonous tree so ease up
huh
feeling wired yet subscribe